[Music]
does jerry not grow mustache stubble
also wearing tidy off-whities the show's
hitting the sad sack jerry punching bag
hard in this opening even insinuating he
flosses while on the toilet but in what
world does someone with jerry's
personality traits even floss at all oh
i couldn't give a [ __ ] about washing my
undies in the sink but gotta take care
of my teeth tweeners rick and jerry
episode breaking the fourth wall to
advertise your episode shortcomings
oversaturating the plumbus market what
did you think it was an execution jeez
you really do need a win is it really
that far-fetched though the truth is the
rick we've been shown in this show is
probably more likely to execute jerry or
manufacture a new one entirely rather
than waste his time trying to give him a
win huh this seems kind of fancy jerry
for all you know this is the equivalent
of an alien truck stop you have no frame
of reference rick would be a master
convincer at tv sins the resort's
covered in an immortality field you
can't die here that's the gimmick i have
questions and thoughts of plenty about
the functionality practicality and
sustainability of an immortality field
far too many to contain in the
parameters of this one sin so i'm going
to sprinkle them in whenever i feel
there's a lull in the cinnable but first
off both rick and his buddy seem to be
in pain when they're harpooned and
glassed immortality should really not be
so appealing when you can still feel the
pain of death rich a-holes are rich
a-holes they all pay top dollar to come
here and enjoy a consequence-free
vacation stealing your idea from
westworld the book or the old movie but
not the new show which came out later so
then we'd send that for stealing from
this this job's complicated mom do you
think i'm hot this entire b plot is
dangerously skippable so i'll use it
instead to untable my immortality field
doctoral thesis next up is the fact that
this isn't technically an immortality
field it's a resurrection and
regeneration field an immortality field
would prevent death from occurring in
the first place and allow you to survive
your injuries regardless of severity
which would make this a [ __ ] horror
escape of a resort where you never die
but have to continuously feel the pain
of any injury or mishap that befalls you
is that a hoof collage it's perfectly
legal if that's what you're wondering
nope i was just wondering why you're
leaving your wine glass directly under
the disembodied hoove sculpture do you
want hoof and mouth disease because this
may or may not be how you get hoof and
mouth disease or could it be her massive
stripper trees in my
limited amount of research i can confirm
there is no specific shape or size of t
required to be a stripper yeah of course
he likes it look at him [ __ ] got
two heads and three trunks that's my
cranial triposcus between the first
whirly and the third durley the ride
dips just outside the immortality field
well that's just terrible theme park
design i don't want to judge an alien
race by its appearance but i do want to
know more about the genetic quirks of
this species for example why does this
individual have nipples when the others
do not and why do they have one bubble
gum stalk and yet our bigger friend here
has two and why are they bumpy when the
smaller chaps are perfectly smooth you
can't give me another new alien race
without the proper information to fill
out my rick and morty decks if she is
this big and the machine's still running
how is she a alive and b not immediately
popping morty like a tomato sauce
balloon the second he tries to squeeze
through there there are some major
issues between you and beth that have
been there since you guys met this is
what apparently tips jerry over the edge
into patricide-in-law this an insightful
statement that's likely based on truth
as opposed to one of the many careless
or hateful things that rick has done
what's worse is that the show never has
a problem making rick out to be the
[ __ ] so why not use this as an
opportunity to show him really
tormenting jerry and jerry finally
breaking what else could reverse
possibly mean in fairness to beth this
is a terrible setting description this
setting should have clearly been called
inside out which still would be
incorrect considering basically all that
happens is the skin inverts but somehow
leaves the eyes and mouth intact man
this is gonna be awesome rick doesn't
find it at all suspicious that despite
the huge line of people waiting behind
him this card is allowed to leave
completely empty other than the two
clearly assassinate looking assassins in
the back that are inexplicably being
allowed to stay on despite having
already partaken in the coaster also how
did the assassins know that this cart
was the card that rick and jerry were
gonna be on and how could they guarantee
that rick and jerry were gonna be at the
front of the line
did jerry just lift up the lap bar
mid-ride that should not be possible i
know this is an animated show but i've
had literal names about this exact
scenario and i need to know that this
should not be possible the assassin
inexplicably waits until rick and jerry
have almost re-entered the resurrection
and restoration field i don't even think
they have a line of sight now instead of
activating a bomb i just assumed this
button was some sort of quick release
mechanism for rick's lab code and what's
concerning about this is i didn't even
question how ineffective and ridiculous
that would be my brain just said yeah
that tracks and i am not okay with how
this show is reshaping my logic center
look i've never managed a resort with a
resurrection and restoration field but
if i did i don't think i'd put the power
source to said field where it was so
open to being damaged i mean look at all
this rock why not bury that way
underground rick and jerry survive this
and you might think that's silly but the
whole episode is about a place with a
resurrection and restoration field and
when you're going to have your character
survive a direct collision with a
mountain and a rocketing wheel of death
your supposed immortality field becomes
about as important as the lowest button
on a button-down shirt i mean it's there
for a purpose but does it really change
much who do you think had more taken
from them when you shot 20 cc's of
liquid dream killer into my daughter
i [ __ ] love the writers of this show
she was rick's daughter jerry she had
options
the monster stopped eating him for a
second to pile on and say oof yeah yeah
two sin removals in a row because the
random forest monster said
i mean balls hilarious i get it but he
could just duck down on the pouch a bit
right also the creature that evolved to
carry its young within punching distance
of its gonads would like a quick
conversation with darwin please kissing
rick's ass isn't gonna help keep him
around mom but it will help you lose
everyone else chapter 47 on my thesis
challenging the r r resort a title that
the owners really dropped the ball on by
not using now that i think about it is
wondering if laws regarding murder and
assault don't apply here i mean you're
still going through the mental and
physical trauma of being attacked and
assaulted so are there just no
repercussions because there's no lasting
physical damage like i lost summer hey
you haven't lost her yet no i definitely
did she's gone there is not a chance
summer would have been able to sneak
away she's too big to miss would shake
the ground when she walked and would be
reigning garage debris it's a synaptic
dampener that blocks violent tendencies
and controversial thought i want cookies
and a 90-minute cut of avatar this show
cuts so deep i [ __ ] love it but
unfortunately i'm dangerously close to
maxing out my sin removals for the
season so i'll just have to send the
cookie monster shade instead wait i know
where she is of course you do how else
would we wrap up two story lines in the
next five minutes ethan and summer were
supposed to go camping and then he dumps
summer the next book in my r r field
series will be dedicated to organized
crime why isn't this resort being
overrun with space mobsters and
criminals that can either use it as a
place to torture their enemies or as a
hideout where they can't be heard by the
authorities using it as a theme park is
wildly undervaluing its potential live
out the rest of your days in denial of
your vagina fantasies it was a one-time
thought that everyone has i mean other
than the people that already have a
vagina right rick and morty episode
steals the best scene from everything
everywhere all at once in the dumbest
scene from doctor strange ii five years
before either of them came out and don't
act like that is impossible in a show
like this oh god i feel like our souls
were united and we're all one with
eternity still a better explanation than
anything i've heard defending the ending
of interstellar
and the final series of volumes will be
spent positing that the r resort should
be swamped by the entire damn universe
this is a place where you not only can't
be permanently killed but it reverses
the thing that killed you so anyone with
a spaceship and a terminal illness can
come here die and be cured of anything
that was killing them this resort should
be the seat of power for the entire damn
multiverse i know giant inside out kaigu
versions of summer and beth are in this
scene but the real monster here is morty
who uses his bare thumb to pat down this
melted marshmallow directly touching the
marshmallow is a surefire way to ruin
any shot you have at not sticking
directly to everything you come in
contact with for the rest of the evening
show takes 21 minutes and 13 seconds to
actually rick and morty
every morning i wake up without a
scratch on me not a dent in the fender
i am an immortal
surprise [ __ ] i'm gonna lay my
head gently on your shoulder
maybe we can cry hug
maybe even slow dance don't patronize me
dean dangerous
rick sanchez you son of a motherless
goat funny monsieur a waffle thin mint
[ __ ] off i'm full the device before you
is one of sacrifice a sacrifice of blood
mean would be shooting you jerry this is
saving a bullet do you comprehend the
value of the bullet in your barrel i
tell you fellas this is the lifeboat